[Music]
we're breaking into programming to take
you to poland that's where the u.s
secretary of state has been meeting with
the polish foreign minister to discuss
the russian invasion of ukraine the
polish foreign minister is speaking
let's listen in and for allied
cooperation within nato as well as
for re-coordination of political
activities in the oec
poland will
never
recognize territorial changes brought
about by
unprovoked unlawful
aggression
the way in which russia
conducts hostilities
based on the desire to break the will of
ukrainian resistance
by means of attacks that terrorize
civilians population
shelling residential areas
nuclear power plants
and non-military vehicles
are war crimes under international law
which are not subjected to statue of
limitation
and will be prosecuted with utmost
determination i call on russia to
refrain from attacks on civilian
populations i call both parties to abide
by international humanitarian law and to
treat
prisoners of war with dignity
tearing over
all war criminals
must be considered in future peace
negotiations
due to its
own painful experience in the past
poland will consequently
demand prosecuting
war criminals
this is our historic debt to the
inhabitants world
where nika and vieluni
whose sacrifices can never be forgotten
pursuing war criminals is an element of
humankind's
common
memory it's our common
obligation to achieve this poland's call
to life
rafal lankin center for documentation
war crimes in ukraine we discuss
possibilities for polish-american
cooperation
in this
area
i
call for an end of a bloodshed and the
cease-fire
for the duration
of the talks between
ukraine and russia in my capacity as oec
chairman in office i welcome the
understanding
for recreation of humanitarian corridors
that will
first
facilitate the evacuation of civilians
from ukrainian cities
cities under siege
along with the majority of oec countries
i
peeled for this
from the outset of a conflict
i view this
understanding
as a ray of hope to prevent more
ukrainian civilians from failing victims
to war everything positive must be done
to ensure the evacuation
russia's aggression in ukraine caused
the humanitarian crisis of an
unimaginable scale
our
priority is organizing effective aid so
hundreds of thousands
and soon be millions of refugees
poland already received
up to
700 000 refugees
and we will continue to do so
for everyone for everyone that
needs it regardless of a nationality
race
or religious creed
the attack on
ukraine already transferred europe and
its sense of security
poland
decided to
immediately increase its defense
spending budget
to three percent of its gmp beginning
next year
as a key country for
deterring and defending nato's eastern
flank poland wholeheartedly
welcomed the alliance's swift reaction
to the new strategic circumstances
and convey to secretary blinken my
thanks to president biden
for his effective leadership
in coordinating an explicit united and
effective response
from the transatlantic community and
with reward
to russia's
aggression
as a host country for
nato response force on the eastern flank
poland plays a critical role
in this reaction and we are determined
to abide by it
in line with the charter of the united
nations
poland will provide all possible support
to ukraine
who is currently defending itself
from an
unlawful as i said unprovoked aggression
thank you secretary blinken thank you um
mr big night i want to thank you as
always for
a very good exchange for the very warm
welcome uh and
we were just at nato together we were in
washington together just
a few weeks ago
and it's very good to be here with you
i'm also
especially pleased that ambassador
brzezinski is now here in poland
credentialed last month
timing could not be better it's vital
that we have
all of our confirmed ambassadors in
place uh at this critical time
um and we are in fact meeting uh at one
of the most urgent moments
in the long history of friendship
between our countries
as allies and partners pulling the
united states
has stood together through many many
challenges
now the very ideals that bind us
freedom democracy peace security
are under threat in this region
uh as never before certainly not since
the second world war
uh the people of poland know how
important it is
to defend freedom
so do americans
and we will stand together
as we've been standing together in
support of ukraine and against russia's
unprovoked unwarranted
premeditated invasion
in nato
at the european union the osce where uh
speegnev is
uh the chair in office this year
poland is doing vital work to respond to
this crisis
it's hosted an increased nato presence
it supported the robust eu sanctions
against russia
and it has done a great deal to
facilitate security assistance to
ukraine
as nato allies
defense cooperation between poland the
united states i think it's safe to say
is closer than it's ever been
uh since january 30th the united states
has more than doubled the number of our
military personnel deployed in poland to
now more than ten thousand including a
brigade of the 82nd airborne division
and we significantly increased the
amount and types of military equipment
and capabilities
that we positioned in poland
as president biden has said
we will defend every inch of nato
territory
poland is also
a leading responder to the humanitarian
crisis that russia's invasion of ukraine
has sparked
as big of just said as of today more
than 700 000 people
have been forced to flee uh the violence
perpetrated by russia by crossing the
border from ukraine to poland with more
coming every single day
i'm going to have the opportunity to
speak to
some of the folks who've come over
just recently from ukraine
but i have to say it's an incredibly
powerful reflection of poland's values
that vulnerable people know that here
they will find refuge
to help support the needs of ukrainians
in poland and other countries
the byte administration just requested
to congress
2.5 excuse me 2.75 billion dollars in
humanitarian assistance
that's both to meet the need of
vulnerable people and communities inside
ukraine
as well as to support refugee services
including here in poland
that's in addition to the more than 54
million dollars in humanitarian
assistance to ukraine that we announced
uh just last week
we also sent a disaster assistance
response team to poland working very
closely with humanitarian agencies to
provide the critical health care safe
drinking water sanitation hygiene
supplies protection for vulnerable
people
especially women and children
we've delivered nearly 20 000 thermal
blankets suited for cold climates we've
provided funding for emergency supplies
to sustain health care for up to one
hundred thousand people for three months
and up to 500 emergency surgical
procedures
embassy kiev has temporarily relocated
to poland as well and i'm grateful for
that
that poland is hosting them
they and our embassies and consulates in
poland and across the region
are working hard to assist american
citizens and their families departing
ukraine and to help them with the influx
of u.s military personnel humanitarian
workers as well as assistants
we established the u.s welcome center
close to the ukrainian border it's been
operating 24 7 since hostility began
we have support teams as well stationed
near the border in romania hungary
slovakia moldova to assist any americans
who are leaving ukraine
at this moment of crisis for millions of
ukrainians
and as the security of europe hangs in
the balance
poland has stepped forward with
generosity
with leadership
with resolve
we're grateful for the strong foundation
of friendship and cooperation that we've
built together over many many decades
which so many are now relying on today
thank you
thank you very much time for some
pictures please
okay that was the u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken and the polish foreign
minister who've been holding a joint
press conference the men have condemned
russia and its invasion of ukraine and
spoken about the humanitarian need
in and around ukraine with its
neighbours let's bring in our
correspondent zain basravi who's at the
crossing on the ukraine poland border
zane first of all let's discuss
the polish foreign minister and what he
had to say what did you make of his
statements and what stood out to you
well what we heard from the foreign
minister is what we've been hearing all
along a great deal of resolve and a
great deal of solidarity with the
ukrainian people you know in many ways
poland truly is the front line it is the
uh uh closest eu country to this
conflict it is the closest nato member
to this conflict and as we heard uh it
is the country that has taken on the
greatest uh share of the burden of
refugees that continue to cross over uh
we've spoken to ukrainians on the other
side of the border who say they are very
grateful for all of the assistance
they've received from poland and poland
is the country that has been helping not
only to provide relief uh as
humanitarian aid but they have also been
the thoroughfare to help to provide a
certain level of arms and armaments uh
to the ukrainians fighting the russian
invasion on the other side so certainly
you know definitely maintaining uh that
in the long term will be what uh will be
required of poland and will be what will
be expected not only from the ukrainian
people but from polls living on this
side volunteering to help as well one
thing we have heard from people that
we've spoken to many of the volunteers
here at the medical border crossing is
that they are grateful they know that
the help is coming but they say that
here at this point the busiest border
crossing uh on the ukraine poland border
here at medica
things are still quite chaotic there are
no translators to help the
many different nationalities that are
crossing over i think uh it is
understandable to see that ukraine is
quite a melting pot so a lot of people
speaking different languages crossing
over and here all that people are trying
to do is get the the the thousands of
people the hundreds of thousands of
people that keep crossing into buses and
onward to reception centers where they
can receive better care but here at this
crossing just a few days ago it was
completely empty all of the supplies
that were brought in all the donations
had been cleared out and the crowds
weren't as big but the ebb and flow at
the border has sort of followed the pace
of uh events happening on the ground in
ukraine so the last couple of days
yesterday today some of the busiest days
since this crisis began over a week ago
zane we also heard from the u.s
secretary of state uh anthony blinken
who said that we stand together against
russia what stood out to you in terms of
what else he had to say was there
anything new from him in that press
conference
well you know anthony blinken's a
presence here in poland certainly a very
strong and symbolic gesture
really drawing a red line in the sand
that poland is is where uh the united
states will stand in solidarity with the
eu and with nato but at the same time
really maintaining uh ongoing policy uh
the united states making it clear that
it will defend every inch of
nato uh allies territory but what we've
been hearing from people here is that
ukrainians see their counterpoints in
the west they see the west as their
allies as well and they say that the
united states nato the eu is not doing
enough to help them uh fight this
conflict with russia the u.s is
maintaining a policy that that does not
want to common to direct conflict with
russian troops and that is a fair
assessment that kind of direct conflict
could lead to a conflict on a more
global scale across the world but the
fact of the matter is the ukrainians
that we've met tell us that if they
could sit across from anthony blinken
now what they would say to him is that
their worlds have already come crashing
down because they are currently at war
with russia
zane poland has obviously played an
important role for ukrainians fleeing
their country but also as a staging
point for sending supplies i'm wondering
if you or your cameraman can kind of
show us a little bit about what's around
you and describe the scene it's
obviously very cold and very busy what
else can you show us and tell us about
the area that you're in
yes of course you make an excellent
point there the weather is becoming a
factor quicker and quicker we're at
about zero degrees here i'm going to get
out of your way and just uh give you a
sense of what's happening around us
the crowd here really gets big and then
is moved on to buses and then taken into
reception centers taken into cities
inside poland taken into cities across
europe and then
just as one bus is filled with people
and the crowd thins more people come
walking across the pedestrian side of
the medical border crossing now uh mr
blinken is likely to uh you know get a
fair assessment of the scale of the
crisis from the different reception
centers from speaking to members of
civil society but what he is unlikely to
see is the sort of uh you know
combination of desperation and relief of
people who have been walking for days
waiting in line for days and hours and
then finally crossing into poland you
know this is where uh they come across
volunteers who bring warm clothes
supplies food diapers
toys i've seen numerous children just
absolutely overjoyed to be handed a
teddy bear or or a bar of chocolate you
know it is a little bit of normal it is
a little bit is a moment of uh relief to
realize that they are across the border
and they are safe this is where people
are preparing hot meals and and serving
them as quickly as they can to people
that then queue up for another line and
then board these buses and we've seen
police officers and firefighters
effectively becoming porters really
helping people to load their bags carry
them onto the buses and
you know people are just carrying with
them
you know the precious little they have
left they've left their homes behind and
only brought what they can carry and
here they actually do
find a moment to sort of
take stock of what's happened before
they go on to other areas but here at
the medical border crossing things are
still quite chaotic and the volunteers
we've spoken to have said that
the polish government certainly is is is
stepping up but there's still need so
much more still needs to be done you
know we've seen
a million people cross over
in little more than a week ukraine is a
country of more than 40 million people
and if there is a big push if there is a
crush of people that has to run towards
the safety of poland in a short space of
time as the violence in ukraine
continues to get worse as russian
soldiers continue to push into
other cities
and push towards kiev then the crisis
here may outpace
the effort of the volunteers but also of
uh the governments and the different
ngos that are working here to try to get
people
the help that they need
yeah certainly i mean hundreds and
thousands of people have fled to poland
what's the general mood like where you
are what's the mood of
the volunteers and also the mood of
ukrainians is there is it one of
defiance is it one of anger is it one of
sadness how can you describe what people
are like there and what they're
experiencing from
an emotional perspective
absolutely that oscillates wildly
from day to day from moment to moment
uh we were interviewing a few people
that just in the middle of the interview
were overwhelmed and had to walk away
you know for the for the mothers the
children the elderly the vulnerable the
civilians crossing into poland is a
moment of of real relief um they may not
know where they're going to next but at
least they know they're safe on this
side of the border they're in eu
territory they're under the protection
of the polish border guard so there's a
great deal of of relief
many of the children aren't really old
enough to understand what's happening uh
but the ones that are old enough to
understand
um you know they have reef safety you
know there's a look of shock on a lot of
people's faces
and then when you come to the emotions
of people going the other way there's a
great deal of anger determination
and urgency
we've been standing here for a few hours
and we've seen at least three or four
different groups of men with heavy packs
medical gear
you know camouflage apparel we've
stopped to ask them where they're going
they're in generally quite a rush and
they say we're medics we're volunteer
fighters we need to know where the
border is we're trying to cross over to
the other side so you know it really
as much as there is uh relief and
anguish and and people who feel
desperate
the men going across to the other side
are are angry determined and
we more there's been more urgency in the
last 24 hours with the people we've
spoken to than we've seen in the last
few days so people are
are going over quicker they're going
over uh to try to get to the front lines
as quickly as possible
zane for people just joining us i just
want to let them know why we're crossing
to you now it's because we've obviously
just had a press conference from u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken and
the polish foreign minister in the south
east of the country where there are
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians
fleeing into poland i guess just for our
audience to recap can you just talk a
little bit about the significance of the
meeting between these two men and what
was said or what was reiterated for our
audience and just keeping in mind that
we have about a minute left on air
yes of course the foreign minister of
poland the u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken who is here to assess
the refugee crisis for himself really
his presence here he's one of the
highest profile world leaders to to
visit this region so far and his
presence absolutely does draw a line in
the sand for any uh russian officials
that may be watching
we've heard a lot of reports and
analysis from uh uh from think tank
saying that uh russia will not stop at
ukraine that that poland will be next
that neighboring countries will be next
and the foreign uh the u.s secretary of
state making clear that the u.s will
defend every inch of a nato territory
that it will
stand strong with its ally poland which
may soon be on the front line of a
conflict if ukraine indeed
does fall to russian forces but what
we've heard from people here is that
ukrainians want a no-fly zone ukrainians
and other europeans are going into the
country as well to join the fight